personally my favorite part was a
special pre Eclipse event that took
place you may or may not have seen it
but we have some footage
take a look alright everybody thanks for
coming out how about a happier host and
executive producer of the Eclipse all
right let me hear you say ich liebe I
said the Sun
listen I just want to quickly thank my
tech team who worked so hard on this
eclipse Josh Hardy Marchi Simmons Kate
LeBlanc Jack Connors max Rendell all the
good people at cloud works our sponsored
entity nice we're ready for you
oh wow all ready okay listen a lot of
people criticize me they say you know an
eclipse is cool but it's no sequel to
the Big Bang listen I figure I'm gonna
leave that to you guys
really close you would Kim Jung anyway
make sure you have god approved glasses
on no forgeries sit back enjoy the show
it doesn't exude the gravitas that I
thought he would no it's a wedding ring
too is that true yeah God had a wedding
God had a wedding ring God like marry
Wow then no effort goes into the
chickweed a God's married Wow
Opus Dei was right okay well anyway
you